it's looking very very very bad in
georgia for the republicans which means
it's looking very
very very bad for the republicans in the
senate
uh the vast vast vast majority of
precincts and votes are in now after
just a little brief pause you know
overnight but but this morning
the votes are in the mainstream media
are on the ground
interviewing totally real republican
voters to get the pulse of the gop
there are a couple of reasons why i came
today one
there's a responsibility i have as a
citizen of the united states
to come out and exercise my right to
vote there's many people around the
world
that don't have this privilege so i want
to do that two
i know that the entire country is
looking at georgia right now
as to what our decision is going to be
so i needed to at least make
my voice be heard through the exercise
exercising my right to vote have been a
lifelong republican this is the first
time i've ever voted
for a democratic candidate just because
there are issues regarding our
environment
regarding taxation regarding
diversity issues and so forth that i
think need to be addressed and i'm
hoping they will be
with a senate that can actually help
encourage and enact uh president biden's
policies does that guy sound like a
lifelong republican to you
he's concerned because he really really
wants to raise taxes
and quote diversity issues whatever that
means
i don't think so doesn't sound like a
republican to me doesn't sound like a
serious news report to me seems a little
bit like a big charade
i'm michael knowles this the michael
knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from
dallas german who said what's the
difference between a cow
and watergate you can't milk a cow for
50 years
that's uh that's true they're going to
keep doing it though this is
this election was worse than watergate
last night in georgia i think that's
that is one thing i guess a lot of
things are worse than watergate but that
one
certainly is uh we've all been stress
eating you know over the past little
while waiting for these results to come
in now i guess over a month we've been
sort of stress eating
probably haven't been taking great care
of ourselves that's why it's a great
time to go
get your beach body beachbody on demand
offers over 1500
at home workouts plus nutrition plans so
no matter what your goals are
they have a program that will help you
build and keep
healthy habits this is the company
behind p90x insanity
and 21 day fix now you can check out
some of beachbody's newest programs like
muscle burns fat
and 80 day obsession get motivated by
celebrity super trainers that you know
like tony horton joel freeman and autumn
calabrese
they have trained millions of people how
to lose weight burn calories
and get totally ripped and i by the way
i fully intend to get totally ripped
i've been a little bad in terms of the
whole exercise thing the past year or so
that changes now and i'm certainly never
going to go to a gym that's not that's
not what i do
but that's why i love beach body go
check it out you can try it absolutely
free 2020 is behind us it is a new year
which means it's time to get in shape
get a special free trial
no obligation membership text knowles
canon wles
to 303030 that is 30 30 30.
you will get full access to the entire
platform all the workouts
nutrition information and support
absolutely free just text knowles can
wles to 30 30 30. that's what i intend
to do
and that's what you should do as well go
check them out
very much looking like we're going to
have senators
ossoff and warnock
everyone's been focusing on warnock
because he's a complete lunatic
and a socialist who hosted fidel castro
at his church when he was
an assistant pastor and who uh his wife
is
ex-wife now or i guess wife ex-wife is
alleging that he uh
tried to run her over with his car that
is that dispute is ongoing
and he's just a complete maniac he said
you can't serve god and be in the
american military
right he's a complete lunatic however
he he drives me less crazy than the
other guy jon ossoff
because warnock is an honest radical
warnock tells you more or less what he
thinks john ossoff
is nothing he's just the same thing
we're seeing again and again from
joe biden and kamala harris and all of
the clintons and all these people he's a
complete empty suit
and he's just a vessel for the
progressive bureaucracy he his
most emphatic campaign point was that we
need to listen to experts
so got a more fouchy that's what he's
just a total contrivance
he's like the beto who could he is he he
and and beto
o'rourke there is and to a lesser degree
p buddha judge they're all the same
person
they were just built in a lab somewhere
by the democratic establishment
and they you have to up update the
software every so often
but but their function is to be a vessel
for
for that establishment
that said we're talking about some other
problems with
maybe the election was the counting all
done on time
how did the votes break at the end i
think it is worth pointing out
lefler and perdue are not great
candidates
uh purdue less so purdue you know
produce okay
lefler did not run a great campaign uh i
had a feeling this would not work out
well for republicans
i have been saying it for days now i i
didn't think we were going to win
uh i actually flew down to georgia to
try to help
campaign a little bit i rarely hit the
campaign trail but i thought it would be
important to win these races and
on the ground there it didn't feel like
the republicans were going to win
that's kind of beside the point to me i
don't really i'm not even thinking
today about the georgia race i'm barely
thinking about the senate
there will be plenty of time to think
about all the insanity that the
democrats will foist on us in the senate
i'm thinking about elections more
broadly i think the reason why people
are very discouraged here is not even
because of all
you know packing the court or adding new
states or ending the filibuster
or whatever other nonsense the democrats
want to push on us
it's because people don't have faith in
the integrity of the elections
and that's not because of kooky
conspiracy theories and that's not
because of
international cabals necessarily it's
because of very simple things that the
left has done
which have undermined the legitimacy of
our elections
namely expanding election day into
election season with
far far less oversight and mainstreaming
the use of mail-in ballots
rather than being this rare exception
now that that is the rule it's mailed
out to everybody those
just those two changes open the
elections up to massive fraud
democrats have been talking about this
for years barack obama was warning about
this
politico magazine a left-wing magazine
was warning about this
until the democrats thought that they
could turn it to their advantage
and now all of a sudden it is a natural
right
we have to unsolicited mail-in ballots
and my feeling
is as long as election day is
election month and as long as
mail-in ballots are the rule rather than
the exception i will have
very little faith in the integrity of
our elections
maybe they'll turn out the way that the
voters wanted
maybe not there's really no way of
knowing it's it's just
so deeply wrong it's deeply un-american
it's it's banana republic kind of stuff
and it's really pathetic
you're going to see a lot of blame game
going around for a little while
the the big culprit you're going to hear
is well they're all going to try to
blame trump of course we'll get to that
in a second
one culprit you're going to hear is lynn
wood linwood is that lawyer
who has been saying that john roberts is
part of like a child rape murder
conspiracy and the
voting machines are all rigged and
linwood is explicitly saying don't go
out and vote in georgia
i don't really blame linwood too much i
mean i think it probably costs some
votes
i don't think it cost a lot of votes i
think a lot of
people who spend their time listening to
politics reading about politics they
spend a lot of time on twitter
and on twitter that's where these sorts
of things flourish i don't think
lynn would cost lefleur and purdue the
election
i think the vast majority of people are
not very
online right there they don't spend all
their time on twitter
and i think they were much more
concerned with why they didn't get their
stimulus bill
their stimulus checks rather i think
they were much more concerned with why
there were so many improprieties during
the election in georgia
the november third election in georgia
why there were so many improprieties in
pennsylvania
for that matter even nationalizing the
issue
i think there was a great ground game i
think the democrats
constructed this system which i think is
right for fraud
but because of that they were able to
use it very well i don't i don't blame
linwood it's easy to blame him because
he's kind of kooky but uh
i i don't think that's it a lot of
people are going to blame trump because
it's all trump's fault right
that to me is completely preposterous
on election night on the actual election
night november 3rd
when trump was on the ballot trump
not well first of all we'll put the
presidential election aside for a second
the republicans
outperformed all the polls when trump
was on the ballot in 2016
when trump was on the ballot in 2020
republicans
outperformed all the polls a lot look in
the house we were supposed to lose seats
in the house we ended up picking up what
10
at least and did better in the senate
than many people thought until
this calamity last night so hard to
blame trump for that
when have republicans really been losing
in these elections in these other
elections
2018 trump not on the ballot and last
night trump not on the ballot
so how are you going to tell me that
it's trump's fault
what you're going to hear is that that
donald trump discouraged people from
voting
in georgia in in this runoff that's
obviously preposterous
trump went down and campaigned for them
tweeted out said vote in georgia
doesn't doesn't hold up but what you're
gonna see is this
this uh race last night these two races
last night
exploited between the two factions of
the
gop the one faction of the gop is going
to be the sort of
mild-mannered mitt romney faction of the
gop
the other faction is going to be the
maga faction of the gop
and these these two factions have
existed for a long
time it goes back many many decades you
see
similarities in the fight between the
rockefeller liberal republicans and sort
of the bush republicans
and the reagan republicans and the
goldwater republicans it's not perfect
analogies
but those have been the two the two
prongs you know the two kind of polar
ends of the
the gop for a long time the guys who
just want to lower taxes and play nice
and go along with the liberal
establishment
and the guys who want to dig their teeth
into the cultural issues
there is another fight going on in dc
right now that the fight going on in dc
right now is over whether or not we will
certify
the electoral college results for the
presidential election
and you're going to hear the same people
in the republican party who hate donald
trump they're going to say this is
unprecedented this is terrible
he's up ending constitutional norms
you're going to hear a lot of democrats
say that too this is unprecedented he's
upsetting constitutional norms
this is not unprecedented democrats do
this
all the time ladies take it away mr
president thank you for your inquiry
2001 democratic representatives on
behalf of my
diverse constituents and the millions of
americans who have been disenfranchised
by florida's inaccurate vote count the
president i arrive on
rise also in 2004 for the congressional
black caucus
to object to the 25 electoral votes
from florida and i am objecting to what
we got another one jesse jackson jr
we're not counting this objective
the hope or even the hint of overture
this is 2005.
of the very timely
and appropriate opportunity to review
and remedy the most precious process
in our democracy i raised this objection
because i am convinced
that we as a body must conduct a formal
and legitimate debate
about election irregularities i raise
this objection to debate the process
and protect the integrity of the true
will of the people
all right it goes on and on we could
play this for several more minutes uh
this is
perfectly normal democrats have been
doing it all the time now basically
but the minute that republicans ever
suggest voicing that opinion goodness
gracious that's an upsetting of norms
you can't do that
the norm is democrats get to do whatever
they want and republicans have to roll
over
well sometimes if you want to make some
political change you got to do it
yourself
if you want to do it yourself on your
own car by the way you got to check out
rock auto now
listen if you go to the brick and mortar
shop you know you often you're going to
get ripped off
don't do that go to rock audio you'll
get the lowest prices all the time
you know that i'm not the biggest car
guy in the world so whenever there's a
problem with my car
in the old days i would go into some
brick and mortar shop and then i would
get ripped off and the person wouldn't
have my part and they'd go online
probably to rockauto.com
then they would order it from there and
then charge me twice as much
rockauto.com makes it so much easier
than walking into a store
and demanding quick answers to things
like is your odyssey
an lx or an ex i don't know what my
odyssey is i don't even know what those
letters mean
a rockauto.com has so many parts for
your car
or truck best of all they make it so
easy to navigate the website that even i
can do it
family owned business for 20 years now
so this is basically as long as
online shopping has existed really
reliable stuff
always reliably low prices rockauto.com
go check it out right now go to
rockauto.com see all the parts available
for your car or truck and then
write knowles k-n-o-w-l-e-s in their how
did you hear about us box
so that they know that we sent you you
know them you love them
go check them out
so this is the the next battle today and
this battle today is going to take place
on capitol hill
in the senate and in the house of
representatives uh
josh hawley and ted cruz have been
leading the fight in the senate to
object to the certification
and i think there's something like 140
republican congressmen
who are going to object in the house
probably not going to amount to a whole
lot in terms of overturning the election
particularly after last night in georgia
it's just just too much momentum
but eric trump the president's son went
on fox news last night he has a warning
for republicans in the senate and in the
house
who do not defend the president who do
not defend election integrity
he says their political careers could
soon be over
i can tell you sean any senator or any
congressman
that does not meaning on this side that
does not fight tomorrow
i'm telling you will not their political
career is is is over because um the maga
movement is going
it's going nowhere my father's created
the greatest political movement in
american history and
i'm telling you they will get primary
the next time around and they will lose
if they don't stand up and show some
backbone and show some conviction
so in terms of what happens today
probably not a whole lot's going to
happen but by the way eric trump isn't
even saying this is going to change the
way the election is going
he's just saying we want you republicans
to stand up and if you don't stand up
your political careers are over and on
this point i think he may be right
this is my main takeaway from georgia
it's my main takeaway from this
certification battle
it's my main takeaway from 2018
my main takeaway is the make america
great again movement the trump movement
is here to stay it's here to stay maybe
donald trump will not be president after
january 20th probably that's going to be
the case
but the maga movement is 100
here to stay
however you want to blame the voters in
georgia
i i would not be surprised if some trump
voters
stayed home just like they did in 2018
because their guy's not on the ballot
because they like trump and they don't
like elected republicans
and it's not just a personality thing i
know it's become very fashionable
on the right to say oh trump they only
voted for him because
he's mean and funny and he's a showman
and all that
sort of also he offered a different
political vision
what you had been getting for decades
and decades and decades on the right
was calls to lower taxes and calls to
roll over on all the social issues
more or less you'd hear some nice
speeches about abortion
but republicans in in elected office
really didn't want to do very much about
abortion
uh the leaders of this you know mitch
mcconnell i don't think he cares very
much about abortion
even even george w bush he was certainly
much better on abortion but
he was a little squishy on certain
bioethical issues certain stem cell
uh lines that sort of thing uh and
bush was one of the good ones more more
usually you got the kind of business
republicans who just talked about
changing you know numbers on a
spreadsheet and trying to
fix the debt a little bit and try to fix
the deficit a little bit
and then forget about immigration
actually not only forget about
immigration you've got to open the
borders it's very good we need more and
more and more
immigration we've got to utterly
redefine marriage we've got to
take everything that really matters to
us
and put that aside so that we can lower
taxes or something
that's not going to work a fellow at the
ethics and public policy center
yesterday tweeted out a graph and it's a
graph i've seen for
a while maybe you have to it's it shows
where political affinities are so let's
say
you're very you know libertarian and
very right-wing or where you know it
kind of shows all
all of the map and it shows that there
are a lot of people who are
fiscally conservative and socially
or i'm sorry fiscally liberal and
socially liberal meaning i know those
words get kind of mixed up but they're
very far to the left on both economics
and on social policy there's a lot of
people down there then there's a lot of
people
who are to the right on social policy
but they're kind of more moderate on
economic policy
and then when you look into this other
quadrant which says
they're say fiscally conservative
socially liberal
there's basically nobody and yet
the fiscally conservative socially
liberal kind of republicans
dominate in the think tanks they
dominate in the media
they dominate in college dorm rooms they
dominate in sort of young republican
politics at least for now
they do not represent any voters
nobody is there and that's why they lose
and they lose and they lose
the great conservative philosopher
edmund burke warned us about this
in reflections on the revolution of
france he said the age of chivalry is
gone that of sophisters economists and
calculators has succeeded it
and the glory of europe is extinguished
forever and then what do conservatives
do they turn right around
and become a bunch of economists and
calculators
no ain't gonna work buddy got to dig
in got to dig in on these issues that's
what trump did
he and he he uh overturned some sort of
long-cherished libertarian policies like
free trade at all costs open borders for
immigration
he overturned that and that's what the
voters want
and and they like him frankly it would
seem to me
since since the republicans do a lot
better when he's on the ballot
than when he's off the ballot it's hard
to conclude anything else
need to get tougher a good example of
this how do we
transform the party so that it's it's
more in line with the maggot party
well you need to get tougher on social
issues there was actually some good news
last night
out of kenosha wisconsin in kenosha
wisconsin
the district attorney announced that
none of the police officers
involved in the jacob blake shooting
case will face charges take a listen to
the d.a
it is my decision now that i announced
today before you
that no kenosha law enforcement officer
in this case
will be charged with any criminal
offense based on the facts and the laws
as i will describe them to you now so it
is our decision that no charge will be
filed
i'm going to also tell you just because
i think it is important
that i that no charge will be filed
against jacob blake
in regards to this incident as well that
for many of the same reasons uh in terms
of
overall discussion about this case that
is not
something that is something that the
district attorney's office intends to
pursue
the left is furious lots of activist
groups are coming on saying this is a
terrible miscarriage of justice
there is a miscarriage of justice here
the miscarriage of justice is that jacob
blake will not be charged for the crimes
he was committing at the time
it's a very good thing that the cops are
not being charged there was absolutely
zero reason why the cops should be
charged if you remember that case
the a woman calls the cops to
her house because this guy jacob blake
allegedly
came in sexually assaulted her it was
true it was a
bad guy who was trying to take her kids
uh he already had a warrant out
uh he then the cops told him hey stop
moving stop what you're doing he
wouldn't stop
he kept walking to his car they tased
him he kept moving they tased him again
he kept moving he then goes to his car
reaches for a knife
and only at that point do the cops shoot
him and we were told this is awful he's
an unarmed
unarmed black man he's this is a racist
racist killing
nothing of the sort so yeah it would be
good if jacob blake were charged and
prosecuted
he won't be politically i understand why
he won't be
the mainstream media are outright lying
about this the washington post tweeted
out quote
police officers won't be charged in
shooting of jacob blake an unarmed black
man who was shot seven times in the back
in kenosha wisconsin
d.a says the trouble with the unarmed
black man theory is the guy
had a knife very important
jacob blake while actively resisting
arms himself with a knife
i continue to hear i think i heard it
the rally last night
the vigil where someone again said he
was unarmed
it is absolutely incontrovertible that
jacob lake was armed with a knife during
this encounter
absolutely incontrovertible that jacob
like was armed with a knife but it
doesn't seem to matter
and this is what something that the left
does all the time
first of all you probably didn't even
hear that fact because the media had
been covering it up and
and a lot of them are not even covering
that presser but
it it doesn't matter whenever the left
constructs a narrative jacob blake's an
unarmed black man
innocent he was killed by theirs they
were shot by the cops then the facts
come out and contradict that
and they say well okay whatever about
the facts in this case
it gets to a greater truth the lie that
we're telling gets to a greater truth
they are so
taken with their own abstract theories
they're so taken with their own ideology
that they will not let reality
get in the way of that and i think a lot
of squishy republicans think oh gosh
they must have a point there must be
something to this whole thing
uh there they must maybe if we try to be
a little conciliatory and meet in the
middle there's no meeting in the middle
these guys are peddling lies and their
lies designed to upend law and order in
this country and upend justice in this
country
and you got to get tough on it that is
some at least a little bit of good news
out of kenosha even as we have to deal
with this very bad news
out of georgia and out of the senate
we have some other good news which is
that the daily wire is
getting into the culture business you
know we always comment on these things
we're always telling everybody else what
to do and someone's got to make a
hollywood studio and someone's got to do
this and someone's got to do that
well we're just going to do it ourselves
we got our first movie coming out run
hide fight
it's going to be available to watch on
friday january 15th at dailywire.com
we're going to be doing a special live
stream premiere the night before
on thursday january 14th on the daily
wire youtube channel
let's kick off 2021 by fighting back on
culture creating our own
content take a listen this is high
school
nothing that happens your matters in the
real world
okay we are in charge now so please pull
out whichever app you use to do live
streaming video get them up and running
and point it at me
now
get down on the ground any more friends
back there
i'm calling 911
you must be close
you should be ashamed
very disturbing news out of vernon
central high school
[Music]
zoey
in between breath take a shot
head on over to dailywire.com become a
member before the movie comes out i have
seen the movie i really really enjoyed
it can't wait to watch it with all of
you
and then we will be right back with a
lot more
i've got breaking news shocking news no
i'm not talking about the senate races
in georgia
i don't really care about that news
anymore it's you know it's going to be
what it's going to be
no i've got a much more shocking news
from nbc
trans women retain athletic edge
after a year of hormone therapy study
fines a new study suggests
transgender women also known as men
maintain an athletic advantage over
their cisgender peers
also known as women even after a year on
hormone therapy oh my goodness
you're kidding me wow it would appear
that the
genius experts with many many years of
medical training
research training mds and phds they have
finally concluded a study that shows
what people with even a modicum of
common sense have always known to be
true
namely that men are physically stronger
than women
can you imagine we have all seen
in recent years as the gender ideology
craze
has swept through schools and swept
through the culture and swept through
sports
there will be some women's track race
and you'll have these two
little 90 pound girls and they're
running in the drag race and then you
get some one
some like 140 pound 160 dude
who has long hair and who is pretending
to be a woman
and wouldn't you know he always wins the
track race
and and then we all have to pretend like
well no maybe
he was on hormone therapy and you know i
don't know he had some kind of plastic
surgery so
maybe it's a fair fight it's obviously
not a fair fight
if you permit men in dresses
to play in women's sports then there's
no such thing as women's sports
i'm not i don't exactly watch the wnba
okay i'm not like i don't even watch the
regular nba
so i the sports thing does not really
bother me from an entertainment
perspective
but it is deeply unfair isn't it i mean
the whole point of title ix
was that women are allowed to have their
own sports leagues and then gender
ideology comes in and says no you don't
and it's kind of funny because title ix
was at the time considered a very
liberal progressive movement
and then it created these women's sports
teams and leagues and
allowed women to get scholarships and
allow women to get awards and
have the glory of playing in games and
then
another left-wing movement a far more
left-wing movement comes in and says
actually women no you don't get you
don't get those sports leagues
this actually ties back into what we
were talking about between the
economics obsessed people on the right
you know just the kind of
mitt romney ben sasse technicrat types
and the cultural fighters
guys like donald trump or josh hawley or
ted cruz or the guys who actually lean
into those questions
the economics obsessed right wing the
basically liberal establishmentarian
right wing
they don't want to talk about this they
what they're going to say is oh come on
how many people are really confused
about their sex
it's obviously a very sad condition if a
guy thinks he's a girl
and so let's just let him look let's
just indulge that delusion let him
compete in the in the women's track race
and he's obviously going to beat the
girls and he's going to take their
scholarships and he's going to take
their awards but
come on let's be it would be nice to him
and frankly i just don't want to deal
with it because i'm over here busy
trying to lower taxes
and allow multinational corporations to
expand and try to open our borders to
flood the country with
illegal aliens and then give amnesty to
them later so come on i'm trying to
pursue all these really important
conservative things
why should i care if
if boys are going into the girls
changing room why should i care about
that's such a minor issue it's not a
minor issue
and and by the way if this were a minor
issue i agree that
the sexual confusion affects a very
small
number of people although it is
spreading like a social contagion the
number of
of uh gen zeirs people below them you
know
younger than the millennials who are
confused about their sex and gender has
skyrocketed in recent years so
it there's both a psychological element
but it also spreads socially
to varying degrees but i agree it
affects a small number of people except
not really if one boy
takes away a scholarship from one girl
that is a political problem
by beating her at girls sports if one
guy can go into the little girl's
changing room
that is a political problem even if it
doesn't happen that often that's a big
political problem
if this issue this the gender ideology
issue were really some minor
issue then why is the left spending
so much time and so much
money and so much energy pushing for it
and when they say who cares well the
left cares
maybe they care for a reason don't
forget the whole this whole bathroom
controversy
can men go into the ladies room this
began
because the left in charlotte north
carolina
decided to allow to pass a bill
to allow men to go into the girls room
they were the aggressors in that culture
war when we hear from the
you know the the squishy republican
types oh give up the culture wars
the conservatives are by definition not
the aggressors in the culture wars
right we're trying to conserve things
we're trying to conserve an old standard
the
obviously the aggressors in the culture
wars are the radicals who are trying to
overthrow those standards
and implement new ones we've we should
talk about this so much more than we
talk about
most economic issues if those squishy
republicans
would put one 100th of the energy
into keeping men out of girls track
meets and men out of the girls changing
room
as they put into trying to keep the
stimulus bill from
uh at six hundred dollars rather than
expanding to two thousand dollars if
they put just one iota
of that effort we would hold the culture
we would be able to construct
something like a sane and sensible
culture you know
speaking of cultural issues i can't i
can't actually can't believe we're
talking about this
i never get into celebrity gossip
stories but i saw one it was trendy on
twitter yesterday
and it's in all the newspapers and it
actually i think sort of matters
kim kardashian and kanye west
are reportedly headed for imminent
divorce
i i i look i
i don't i wish them both well i'm
actually very sad to hear this
and i know a lot of other people are
very sad to hear this people seemed
actually devastated in the comment
sections
on social media and i thought why is it
you've got a thrice married ex-porn star
kim kardashian
married to a very eccentric rapper
why are people so shocked and saddened
that this marriage is coming apart
the reason is because our marriage
culture
has been so incredibly degraded right
marriage rates are at an all-time low
uh people often expect to get divorced
even if they're
if they get married that their marriage
actually seemed relatively stable and
because kanye west
is relatively conservative for people in
hollywood
not just because he put on the maga hat
but because he goes to church
because he practices religion because
he is vocal about that because
apparently when he was making that
that gospel album he told the the people
working on the album he said no
fornicating while you're working on this
album
i thought whoa man this is this is
pretty
conservative stuff
i i get it i it tells you a lot about
the state of this culture
that the west kardashian marriage
is something we're all hoping will last
as an instrument of stability or as
a symbol of stability and true love and
all that sort of thing and i do wish
them well and i hope they don't get
divorced it's very divorce is a very bad
thing
they got a lot of kids and and
as bizarre as their life is
it it will it will somehow
degrade the culture even further if they
if they get divorced i
it will there there is i don't think
that all the
fanboys and fan girls who were
complaining about this on social media
yesterday i
i think that comes from a genuine a
genuine cultural angst
we're always decrying the collapse of
the culture especially conservatives
that's sort of our favorite hobby is to
say oh it's all over you know it's the
fall of rome
and we've got nowhere to go from here
and it's all over
i saw a couple news stories the other
day that
put this into perspective for me in
december the
the last publicly documented widow of a
civil war veteran
died it the year
is now 2021 so last month it's the last
month of 2020.
and in 2020 the widow
of a civil war veteran died
there was a little bit of an age gap she
was 17 he was 93
but they were married they have the
documents to prove it
they were married for a few years before
he died she never remarried also
helen viola jackson died at the age of
101 years
her husband private james boland fought
for the union in the 14th missouri
cavalry
uh she never he he married her in in
part because he wanted to make sure she
was set up for life
and uh to give her his pension she never
applied for it
and she never remarried and that was it
two months before that
the grandson of our nation's tenth
president
died president john tyler his grandson
died three months ago tyler was
president from
1841 to 1845. obviously you know
tyler was very old and he had his son
and his son was very old when he had
this grandson
nevertheless this is a very young
country that's my big takeaway from it
this is a very young country
and when we're this kind of cuts both
ways you're going to hear a lot of sort
of
squishy types over the next few days say
oh listen
the the country has survived greater
difficulties than this
look you don't need to worry about the
integrity of our elections in this
country we're the greatest democracy in
the world
you don't need to worry about the
structure of our
civil institutions look we're a very
we're a strong country leading country
in the world
it's a young country it's a young
country and
things have been good generally good
until now i mean we did have a civil war
there were two
two world wars we had massive civil
unrest in the 1960s
uh so yeah i mean it's been basically
good until basically stable until now
civil wars aside but it's a young
country and a lot of things could still
happen
on the other side you're going to hear
people say look this is going to get
really bad and if
if warnock and ossoff are in the senate
and kamala harris is the tie-breaking
vote we're going to end the filibuster
pack the supreme court
add new states they're already talking
about it adding dc
adding puerto rico adding the
philippines i don't know adding guam
whatever so that democrats then have a
permanent majority i mean these are
things that are being openly spoken
about it
at the highest levels of politics
those things could happen i'm not saying
they will
but i'm saying they could this is a
young country the
what's driven me craziest about the
whole last month or
month and a half of uh since the
election is
people on both sides talking about this
is unprecedented this has never happened
before first of all in a young country
there are going to be a lot of things
that are unprecedented
and it's not going to stop you from
doing them but also there have been
precedents
objecting to the certification of
electoral votes
that's very precedented democrats do it
all the time now
and and we had a major constitutional
crisis in the 1870s over it
adding new states to the union for most
of our country's history we've added new
states to the union
the idea that we couldn't add a new
state now crazy
the the reason that it would be
difficult to do it now is because it
would upset the balance of power in the
country
much like you saw in the 1850s and then
you know what happened
after the 1850s so what do we do
now i think the most immediate thing to
do
right now so much of this came because
of covid
and specifically the lockdowns you're
going to blame trump you're going to
blame lynn wood you're going to blame
mitch mcconnell you're going to blame
stacey abrams you're going to blame
whoever
if not for the excuse of kovid these
lockdowns wouldn't have happened and the
use of widespread mail-in votes which
are intrinsically vulnerable to fraud
would not have happened and the
expansion of election day to election
season very likely would not have
happened you've got to end this crazy
covid stuff
and there's a guy doing just that down
in florida who just shut down
a cnn reporter governor ron desantis
pretty tough republican down there he
was asked about his covet policies
he he tried to answer the question but
he wouldn't let
cnn filibuster governor what has gone
wrong with
governor what has gone wrong with the
rollout of the vaccine that we've seen
phone lines jammed websites crashed a
lot of demand i mean i think at the end
of the day
excuse me excuse me if i could finish my
you just said what has gone wrong so i'm
answering the question if i could
complete the question though
so are you going to give a speech are
you going to answer ask a question
without do respect
you asked the question i'm going to try
to finish no
you're you're you're giving a speech you
asked a question i am trying to ask you
you're going to ask how many questions
you get three they only got one question
why do you get three with all due
respect governor i'm just asking if i
could
finish my question you didn't you
finished the question i did not my full
question is what went
wrong with the rollout of the vaccine
when we've seen phone lines jammed
websites to complete it for you
governor we've seen websites crash and
also
senior citizens waiting overnight for
the vaccine where was that at
we've seen it in duvall broward orange
and lee county why was like in lee why
did that happen
did you investigate why that's my
question to you governor you're the
governor of the state i'm not the
governor of the state
okay but you didn't investigate why that
like in lee county
why was there a big line did you did you
investigate why
she absolutely did not investigate and
it turns out it's because the
the there were the hospitals did not
take reservations and there were people
who showed up and obviously there's
nothing the state can do about that
i love this attitude though with the
media this is
dare i say it a trumpy attitude and i
think one of the reasons desantis is
being talked about as one of the leading
contenders in 2024
is because he's got that kind of trumpy
spirit to him you know it's not just
trump it's other people too though trump
most recently embodied him that is going
to be the future of the party or the
party is not going to have very much of
a future
now on this topic of healthcare
on this topic of the covid vaccine and
the rollout and everything
the way cnn wants to spin it is that
people are clamoring they're waiting
overnight to get the vaccine everybody
wants the vaccine
and the republican governors are totally
bundling it and forget about it when the
democratic governors bungle it no big
deal like in california new york no no
but forget nothing to see here
that's not the whole story though if you
look in new york
one third of healthcare workers
who are eligible to get the coronavirus
vaccine are not getting it they don't
want to get it not just in
in new york if you go to riverside
county california
half of hospital workers who have been
offered the covid vaccine
are choosing not to receive it and in
california there's a very slow rollout
of only about one percent
of californians have received that
vaccine
even these healthcare workers who i
don't think should be prioritized i
think older people who are actually
more vulnerable to this virus should be
prioritized i don't think the nurses and
the doctors should
but the nurses and the doctors who who
have been offered it
very often don't want the vaccine and i
don't blame them they're healthy and
young and they don't need it
and the the threat of this
virus on young healthy people has been
extraordinarily exaggerated
by political activists in the mainstream
media
but i repeat myself so sure they don't
want it
and what's another reason they don't
want it they don't want it because there
are side effects you don't need to take
my word for it
you don't you don't need to take the
word of a crazy conspiracy
anti-vaxxing campaign somewhere
even nbc admits in a pro-vaccine article
an article that explicitly castigates
quote-unquote anti-vaxxers
even nbc is admitting there are side
effects to the coronavirus vaccine
the side effects include fevers
headaches joint pain fatigue
which if if you know anybody who's had
the coronavirus
uh that's basically what it feels like
right
so i think for a lot of people who are
young and healthy who are not at an
extreme risk of say hospitalization or
death
they're thinking why would i get that
when vaccines usually take years and
years and decades and decades to make
why would i be the first guy in line for
a vaccine that was made in six months
it's a prudent approach that's a an
approach that takes account of risk
and it's not tinfoil hat wearing right
wingers who are taking that approach
it's
healthcare workers in new york and
california
makes perfect sense and frankly what
what desantis is doing is
pretty smart prioritizing people who
need it and
allowing the state to stay open and
allowing people to go live their lives
and i suspect if states had taken that
approach for the past several months
the elections would have turned out
differently maybe that's why they didn't
take that approach maybe that's why they
locked down everything and everyone and
totally changed voting procedures in
some states
in violation of the state constitutions
maybe that's why maybe this is all just
a really really big
power grab fighting back against it's
going to help desantis if
he's running in 2024 which it looks like
he is another guy that's clearly
running in 2024 at least as of now is
josh hawley
josh hawley is taking uh he's
taking the fight to the senate on the
certification of the ballots
he's positioned himself as what you
might call a common good
conservative same kind of thing he's
he's
upending the kind of libertarian
orthodoxy that became fashionable for
the last 15 or 20 years
and he's saying nah there's a deeper
conservative tradition here and that
whole fiscally conservative socially
liberal uh and really what you're saying
is fiscally libertarian
socially liberal voter group they don't
really exist
so i'm gonna forget about that i'm gonna
run as a more traditional conservative
that guy's doing pretty well and the way
you can tell he's doing well
is that antifa is trying to kill him and
his family so
the other night josh hawley's house is
attacked by antifa
these lunatics are screaming in bull
horns they're banging they're trying to
bang down the door
this is where holly's wife lives this is
where holly's children
sleep very very bad stuff and every one
of those
goons should be thrown in prison and
have the key thrown away
for doing that sort of thing imagine
doing that terrorizing a guy's
wife and children so hawley comes out
and says these antifa scumbags were
terrorizing my kids
this is how the washington post reports
on it quote
senator josh hawley says antifa scumbags
terrorized his family's virginia home
police called the protesters peaceful
the protesters peaceful what protesters
banging on some guy's door
in the middle of the night that's not
peaceful screaming at his kids
through bullhorns that's not peaceful
this is the same washington post by the
way that says that uh
that jacob blake was an unarmed black
man shot by the police right so
you can tell how reliable they are
i don't really know that much about
hawley i haven't i just haven't looked
into him that much i don't know him
personally i've never spoken to him
uh but one mark in his favor
is that you you know a guy by his
enemies and
if if josh hawley's enemies are the
washington post and antifa if they think
he's such a threat
that they're going to go over there and
try to knock down his door well
i suppose that's a mark in his favor
so what do we do now what do we do now
2024 is still a little while away i
guess who knows maybe president trump
would run in 2024
assuming things don't work out today
well assuming things don't work out
today assuming hawley
and cruz and the other senators and the
congressmen do not overturn the biden
transition
we really really need to undermine
kamala harris we mentioned yesterday
this story that kamala told
of uh of how she was
a little child and she was taken to a
protest and she fell out of her seat you
know
and and then she was asked what did what
is
what is she there for and she says
freedom freedom that's the story that
she was told right
and uh but it's not true she stole it
from martin luther king
how do you steal from martin luther
there was an interview that king gave to
playboy well it turns out kamala has
used this story a lot she used it
on book tv on c-span she's used it in l
magazine she's used it all the time
she is a
shameless and professional liar and i
think one thing you could see is a lot
of gaslighting a lot of
people telling you there's no question
about election integrity no mail-in
votes are wonderful and no there's no
question
we shouldn't have any voter id you know
we need election season we'll keep don't
we're going to take a pause on counting
the votes tonight but we'll get you the
results in three weeks when we when we
figure out exactly how many ballots we
need
there's a lot of gas lighting we're
going to need to stand our ground this
is not
the time to go squishy all right that's
it i'm michael knowles this is the
michael nola show see you tomorrow
she would look down at me and calmly
what do you want what do you want
and i looked back up and i said freedom
the michael knoll show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadovsky editor and associate
producer danny d'amico
audio mixer mike coromina hair and
makeup by nika geneva
and production assistant mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 2021. you know the
matt wall show
it's not just another show about about
politics i think there are enough of
those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about i
hope you'll give it a listen